les amis l'album est sorti ya un mois
avec holly on est en train de le fêter
bien qu'à de rennes tous les deux
[Applaudissements]
hu
ça y est c'est la joie les amis c'est la
joie les aubergines ont rejoint les
tomates je répète les aubergines ont
rejoint
[Rires]
jean et ça c'est de la tomate
bon appétit bien sûr
gas de sang
[Musique]
j'ai vu sur internet que tom cruise et
moi on avait le même âge on sort nos
films en même temps top gun et ducobu
est bon on fait pas la même cascade
tiens
[Musique]
salut tout le monde les gens alors là il
ya un pote qui arrive qui s'appelle
folman on l'appelle folman passe yeux il
n'est pas capable de passer trois
minutes sans avoir le téléphone greffé à
l'oreille et sa femme en a ras-le-bol
alors elle nous a demandé de le loger
voici donc la vengeance de la femme de
fans
ben oui le chien que si c'est aussi un
méchant
aux fraudes man ça va ma poule
tu as tes papiers sur ton
voix folle
bon ben voilà le tournage de new delhi
n'ait terminé une aventure incroyable